paris dans le 1er arrondissement
derrière cette vitrine discrète un
restaurant très prisée des amateurs de
vins
[Musique]
une fois par mois olivier schwartz le
maître des lieux invite ses clients à
éduquer leurs palettes avec une
dégustation à l'aveuglé mais très très
bon jeu c'est la première chose de
vraiment influé s'est pas loupé cette
fois olivier leur réserve une surprise
dans cette bouteille un vin de
consommation courante vendus en grande
surface
c'était une odeur de devrait ascquois
non vraiment il ya beaucoup d'acidité
ans en fin de bouche là on sent bien que
ça ok des gros problèmes de brûlures
d'estomac des angoisses
on sent on sent bien quand même que
c'est trafic et à la base vous pouvez
pas savoir le nombre de choses qu'on
peut rajouter dans la terreur il ya les
petits paquets argenté là qu'on peut qu
on peut rajouter un peu dans toutes les
cuvées pour a des goûts différents pour
rectifier ci est trop d'acidité et pas
assez quoi manger on peut faire
absolument ce qu'on veut avec le vin ce
caviste à raison aussi étonnant que cela
puisse paraître le 20 symbole du terroir
français n'est pas forcément un produit
100% naturel
la plupart des producteurs de vins
utilisent des additifs chimiques qu'ils
ajoutent dans leurs cuves même si la
majorité de ces produits est sans danger
le consommateur n'est jamais averti
à quoi servent ces additifs pourquoi ne
sont ils pas mentionner sur les
étiquettes de nos bouteilles
nous avons découvert que pour vendre
plus cher leur vin certains producteurs
rajoute plus d'additifs
au delà de la limite légale
mais il ya plus grave le vignoble
français consomment chaque année des
milliers de tonnes de pesticides
certains produits cancérigènes se
retrouvent dans nos verres sous forme de
résidus tous les vins sont il contaminé
et sont ils dangereux pour le
consommateur pendant plusieurs mois nous
avons enquêté dans le vignoble français
pour savoir pourquoi et comment certains
producteurs de vins fabrique ses cuvées
chimiques
[Musique]
notre enquête débute pendant les
vendanges sur la piste des additifs
chimiques ici sur des centaines
d'hectares
le raisin est ramassé à la machine et
non à la main il n'y a pas de
vendangeurs car la machine divise par
quatre le coût de la récolte en deux
semaines des centaines de tonnes de
raisins sont ramassés direction la plus
grande cave coopérative de france peu de
main d'oeuvre là aussi presse automatisé
trieuse mécanique fermentation accéléré
nous sommes dans le temple de la
viticulture moderne 8 millions de litres
de vins sont produits ici chaque année
les deux tiers sont vendus en grandes
surfaces entre 3 et 8 euros
à l'intérieur de la cave des dizaines de
cuves de plusieurs centaines
d'hectolitres où sont élaborés vin rouge
blanc ou rosé
s'est effrité
ce matin eric dubois le neurologue en
chef de la cave est au travail
c'est la deuxième jeu
c'est lui qui élaborent tous les vins de
la coopérative des dégustations
s'enchaînent tous les jours il doit
goûter plus de 150 cuvée pour s'assurer
que la vinification se passe bien
voyez toutes leurs couleurs
zim 2008
un grand millésime une bonne nouvelle
mais ici un bono log doit surtout savoir
faire un vin marketing faire du vin
c'est bien mais il faut le vendre
il faut s'adapter aussi à la
consommation les consommateurs actuels
belle des vins rouges sur le fouillis
sur la souplesse
avec de la rondeur un petit peu de
sucrosité et comment vous le savez alors
fallu ça parce qu'on a des études conso
qui sont faites
au niveau de la cave on voit bien que
doit avoir des choses qu'ils sont
à soyaux
j'aimerais
alors pour fabriquer un vin le plus
tendance possible
certains producteurs de vins utilise des
artifices que vous ne soupçonnez pas des
additifs qu éric dubois le neurologue
n'a pas souhaité nous montrer en
insistant il accepte tout de même de
nous présenter un petit sachet qu'ils
ajoutent dans le vent c'est un paquet de
levure sèche active
en fait qu'on
on utilise uniquement pour
des levures naturelles dont
on en fait on en rajoute uniquement pour
être sûr
s'il est un peu gêné c'est que ces
levures ne proviennent pas de son
terroir
elles ont été cultivées en laboratoire
ça vous un truc ce petit paquet c'est
levure accélère la fermentation et sont
utilisés par 90 % des producteurs sur
internet en accès libre
les viticulteurs peuvent acheter toute
une panoplie de produits des poudres
qu'ils ajouteront dans leurs cuves en
fonction du vin souhaité nous en avons
nous mêmes commandé sur internet gomme
arabique que 414 pour donner de la
rondeur bicarbonate de potassium e500
angle pour gommer l'acidité acide
ascorbique et 300 pour préserver la
fraîcheur pour le vin il existe une
quarantaine d'additifs autorisé par la
législation européenne pour obtenir les
arômes fruités tant appréciée du
consommateur certains industriels du vin
ont une botte secrète
les levures aromatiques qui sont ceux
qui fabriquent ces produits
notre enquête se poursuit dans le
beaujolais dans un domaine viticole très
discret c'est une cave expérimental une
sorte de laboratoire de recherche ou les
additifs utilisés dans les vins sont
testés avant d'être commercialisé ce
matin l'équipe est justement en train
d'expérimenter une nouvelle levure pour
les vins blancs
on accompagne dans ces cas là
jean luc berger le directeur technique
accepte de nous révéler les secrets de
fabrication du vin industriels car les
arômes du vin ne viendrait pas que du
terroir souvenez vous du fameux goût de
banane qui a fait la renommée du
beaujolais nouveau
en fait ils provenaient de la levure 71
b qui a été expérimenté dans ce
laboratoire dans le beaujolais
c'était le produit star pendant dix ans
mais aujourd'hui cette levure n'est plus
à la mode
[Musique]
la room de bananes qui avait été en fait
développé à une époque avec l'a71 baissé
quelque chose que l'on a arrêté parce
que justement c'était trop caricatural
c'est à dire que c'était une pure comme
ça qu'on a utilisé là pour préparer mais
qui en fait était trop autres simples ne
donnait qu'un arômes de milan et du coup
ça rendait le
le vin repérable quand il avait été fait
remonter par cette mesure je pense pas
qu'ils aient tromperie du consommateur
simplement on a stabilisé le process
fiabiliser le process autrement dit
faire baisser les coûts de production
pourtant il existe des levures
naturellement présentes sur le raisin
mais les industriels préfèrent utiliser
des levures cultivées en laboratoire qui
permettent une vinification plus rapide
alors un vin fabriqué avec de tels
additifs est il encore un produit du
terroir
nous nous rendons en alsace sur le
vignoble de jean pierre frick
ici il cultive ses vignes sans engrais
ni pesticides chimiques
les vendanges sont faites exclusivement
à la main on va changer
si vous en mettez encore 5
au jus de raisin ce vigneron ne rajoute
aucun additif ni aucune levure pourtant
son vin est connu dans le monde entier
et s'exporte même au japon depuis 20 ans
jean pierre frick dénonce l'ajout de
levure aromatiques par les industriels
après produits de terroir on n'est pas
d'additif je suis désolé en vain terroir
on met pas de levure qui oriente vers la
cerise ou qui apporte plus de finesse ou
plus d'ampleur on laisse faire les
levures qui sont issus de ce terroir ça
c'est du terroir donc dans ce sens il y
a un petit peu on prend quelquefois le
consommateur pour un gogo dans dans les
arts hausse et des appellations
d'origine contrôlées ne levurage à mon
sens devrait être interdit mais pour se
passer totalement d'additifs et
préserver le goût du terroir
jean-pierre exige un travail d'orfèvre à
la vigne chaque grain et délicatement
cueilli étrillé à la main ça c'est du
vinaigre et l'insa ça s'enlève il y en a
très rarement mais bon ça il faut le
virer
salut les plus belles grappes seront
pressés pour faire du vin c'est une
grappe qui est bien aérée qui éclaire
entière il n'y a pas beaucoup de grains
qui sont écrabouillé et ça pour nous
c'est important parce que quand c'est
écrabouillé on a plus de werder
dans les vins balogou un petit peu amer
vert avec une machine une machine prend
tout et puis dans ce cas là on sulfites
pour aseptiser tout ce à quoi les
sulfites
encore un nouvel additif chimique
utilisée par 99% des producteurs de vins
problème se produit là n'est pas
totalement inoffensif pour le
consommateur pour mieux comprendre
nous retournons dans le laboratoire de
recherche du beaujolais démonstration
avec cette bonbonne verte
donc voilà le la réserve de susic les
sulfites c'est du soufre à l'état gazeux
que les vignerons injecte dans les cuves
un conservateur très efficace qui
empêche le vin de tourner au vinaigre
mais c'est aussi un produit toxique car
si les dosages sont très contrôlés il ya
toujours un risque pour la santé du
consommateur
qu'est ce qui peut leur arriver à ces
gens là
alors il peut y avoir des réactions eux
cutanées des de type allergique en fait
mais c'est son premier terminant des
allergies laisser des réactions de type
allergique
ça provoque aussi des maux de tête par
exemple quand tu verras centre-sud coûté
au niveau qui consomment du vin et
pourquoi est ce qu'on continue à
l'utiliser alors la raison pour laquelle
dans utilise c'est que malgré
c
ces inconvénients sur le plan de la
santé oms n'a pas trouvé
et il produit plus plus intéressant que
le sauver depuis deux ans sur toutes les
bouteilles de vin un logo averti les
femmes enceintes qu'elles ne doivent pas
consommer d'alcool et depuis peu est
aussi apparue en petits caractères cette
mention contient des sulfites
personne n'y prête attention à part les
asthmatiques
ce sont eux les plus sensibles aux
sulfites ils risquent des troubles
respiratoires et même des pertes de
connaissance or il suffit de boire
quatre verres de certains vins liquoreux
pour dépasser la dose journalière
recommandée
en plus d'être dangereux pour la santé
les sulfites peuvent aussi dénaturer le
goût du vin retour en alsace chez le
vigneron qui travaillent sans additifs
chimiques
ce matin jean pierre frick accueille un
couple de restaurateurs qui a décidé de
se tourner vers des vins plus naturel
c'est ce que je vous propose un tout
petit peu d'eau d'abord qu'on se rend
c'est un petit peu ils viennent de
parcourir 800 kilomètres pour
s'approvisionner chez jean pierre frick
et ce matin il leur propose une
étonnante dégustation alors je vous
propose une petite comparaison est donc
vous donnerez vos impressions et vos
préférences
un test à l'aveuglé d'un côté un vin
blanc sulfites et de l'autre le même vin
sans sulfites ajoutés verdict pour le
vin sulfites et oui mais très ferme
pas d'odeur particulière lequel il reste
qu il reste collé jeter quant aux vins
sans sulfites
moi j'aime bien la couleur déjà honni
sent qu'il est un peu pierre pierre
generali minérale qu'à lyon moi je
propose même ça fait appel à mes
souvenirs d'abricot de un peu fruits
confits et puis au palais je le préfère
quand on peut revenir vers le bio
j'avoue que on vient vers le bio
pourquoi eh bien à cause de sa cause de
ces de ses arômes de ces palettes de
cette richesse et point de vue santé je
pense qu'il ya pas photo pourquoi on a
pas mal aux cheveux c'est clair j'ai pas
mal aux cheveux quand je vois bio 1 et
je picole
mais le vin bio n'est pas forcément sans
additifs chimiques
le label ab garantie seulement l'absence
de pesticides dans les vignes mais il
autorise l'ajout de sulfite ou de
levures aromatiques dans les cuves
seuls les vins naturels sans soufre
comme ceux de jean-pierre sont fabriqués
sans produits chimiques
mais ces vins n'ont pas de label alors
difficile de s'y retrouver
certains vignerons milite pour plus de
transparence sur le contenu des
bouteilles
je suis favorable à ce qu'on mette tout
ce qui est dedans et de cette manière là
ça nous tient
non viticulteur à m de moins en moins de
choses parce que le consommateur plus il
ya de ligne 2 ligne d'additifs moins ça
fait bien quoi un bon on le fait pas
parce qu'il ya des lobbys j'avais grands
lobbys le on nous trompe on trompe parce
aux informations le consommateur un peu
en permanence cette absence
d'information est parfaitement autorisé
la loi n'oblige pas les producteurs de
vin a indiqué sa composition sur
l'étiquette
contrairement à tous les autres produits
alimentaires mais certains viticulteurs
n'hésite pas à se mettre hors la loi
pour frauder ils ont recours à un
produit que l'on utilise d'habitude pour
les sodas ou les confitures le sucre
notre enquête nous conduit à nouveau
dans le beaujolais dans cette région
l'ajout de sucre dans le vin est
autorisé pour augmenter le degré
d'alcool jusqu'à une certaine limite de
2 degrés une pratique courante qu'on
appelle la chaptalisation pour mieux
comprendre
nous allons chez daniel bulliat c'est le
plus gros vignerons du beaujolais sur
les trois mille exploitants que compte
la région raconte comment ça s'est passé
les vendanges ouais c'est comment c'est
donc le 22 septembre
beaucoup de travail mais ces data
centres chez ce vigneron trois tonnes de
sucre sont stockées bien sûr bien sûr
j'ajoute du sucre dans mon vin et c'est
vrai que la réglementation aujourd'hui
nous autorise à chaptaliser en
beaujolais en bourgogne dans toutes nos
zones de production à 2 degrés c'est à
dire ça correspond à 36 grammes pour
être précis à 36 grammes de sucre par
litre
c'est pas du tout tabou puisque ça
améliore la qualité c'est réglementé
s'est construit par nos administrations
très sévèrement
on a des cahiers le sucre âge qu'on doit
représenter tout est déclarée lorsque la
récolte est mauvaise le vent n'atteint
pas le degré d'alcool requis la cuvée
risque alors de perdre
l'appellation d'origine contrôlée alors
plusieurs années de suite certains n'ont
pas hésité à dépasser la dose de sucre
autorisée
c'est ce qu'on appelle la sueur
chaptalisation une pratique interdite
qui met en colère les représentants des
vins du beaujolais
de quoi non pas du tout non non non on
chante ali zouaoui mais on fait pas la
sueur chaptalisation ce qu'ils ont fait
mais il faudra qu'ils éprouvent pourquoi
ils l'ont fait si c'est pour mettre un
kilo de sucre
plus parce qu'ils n'avaient pas le degré
bref on va pas jeter la pierre
mais si c'est pour pouvoir faire des
vins qu'ils n'avaient pas droit à
l'appellation bon alors on est très
déçus parce que c'est pas correct
hélas alors sont des faux frères donc là
on n'a pas d'accord des faux frère le
président des vins du beaujolais parle
de cinquante trois viticulteurs qui
auraient fraudé pour obtenir la hausse
et et vendre ainsi leurs vingt deux fois
plus cher
en 2004 il aurait acheté sans facture
600 tonnes de sucre avec la complicité
de plusieurs enseignes de la grande
distribution
tout est parti de ce supermarché situé
dans une petite ville de l'ain en 2006
les agents de la répression des fraudes
constate une anomalie dans les stocks de
sucre du magasin ils découvrent que des
centaines de palettes auraient été
vendues sans facture à des transporteurs
routiers un marché parallèle dans lequel
quatre directeurs de magasin de la même
enseigne sont impliqués sur cette
affaire la direction générale de la
chaîne de supermarchés ne souhaite pas
s'exprimer
[Musique]
nous tentons de rencontrer l'un des
transporteurs routiers qui aurait écoulé
une grande partie des 600 tonnes de
sucre en provenance des supermarchés
bonjour moi j'étais une chose j'ai
acheté sera dur gérant de soumettre mais
c'est un problème liquidateur chaque
nation sur chaptalisation marché
parallèle et changement l'homme accepte
de nous recevoir dans son bureau il
confirme l'existence d'un trafic
organisé
[Musique]
qui allie culteurs qui a la cote ces
temps de jeu
regard ça je suis à new york
mais pourquoi sans facture c'était quoi
le coach voulait c'était sur combien
d'années tout ça une carte du monde
[Musique]
c'est donc sur 3 ans 600 tonnes de sucre
ça vous paraît anormal d'accord en
janvier dernier le transporteur comme 60
autres prévenus se retrouve devant la
justice
ce jour là ils comparaissent pour
falsification de produits juste une
petite question de l'habitat
l'ambiance est tendue
parmi les prévenus un homme attire
particulièrement l'attention du
procureur abel prennent à un retraité du
monde viticole qui serait le cerveau du
trafic
est ce que vous l'avez fait que j'aie la
vente du sucre
m
[Musique]
étonnamment quelques minutes plus tard
son avocat ne nous donne pas du tout la
même version
vous dites que ce n'est pas vous qui
avez acheté une pulsion
un peu quand même
- un petit peu
mais rien à voir avec eux
les tonnages qu'ils avancent à part dans
ce qu'ils reprochaient c'est quand même
l'organisation d'un trafic et de vente
illégale exquis reprocher c'est d'avoir
répondu un viticulteur qui dit est-ce
que je jette ma récolte ou
est ce que je la surchaptalisé de 0,3
0,2
je mets un petit peu plus dessus seul un
petit peu plus de sucre
on sait que s'il va l'acheter avec
facture moins de contrôles montrera que
il assure japd alizés
c'est pour ça que
à ce moment là soit avec son caddie au
supermarché
on voit sa fin quatre fois de suite qui
prend chaque fois 20 kg n'y a pas de
problème
ainsi non sinon ils s'approchent de
quelqu'un d'aimable quand même monsieur
très bon alors qu'il eût dit moi je peux
trouver le sien c'est lui qui est allé
chercher on parle pas de ta dit on parle
de l'automne c'est un gros calibre
c'est recommencer je crois
[Musique]
les avocats des vignerons joue les
optimistes mais ils savent que cette
affaire risque de ternir durablement
l'image du beaujolais
alors pour tenter de mettre la presse de
leur côté ils emploient des méthodes
pour le moins surprenant tout simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour le démontrer à la baisse nous
avons plus que le navire pris
l'initiative de vous qu'on lui
d'eclagnens a suspendu et midi
une petite dégustation
mon vrai niveau
juste en face du palais de justice les
avocats ne reçoivent dans leur cabinet
toute la presse est conviée
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse le plus on
a très vite nous tant qu'à faire autant
déguster il ya des creux il ya
différents vins c'est une fois la robe
est tombé la transformation est totale
les avocats deviennent des vrp du
beaujolais exagérons rien il faut
affluent ces personnes c'est la
neutralité absolue être ajoutés mais
mais mais c'est qu'ils aient pas
survivre
non c'est simplement pour des moins 5
on a beau jeu l'est est bon à boire le
beaujolais et thomas c'est vrai on a dit
que c'est un match qu'on a dit que
c'était à 20 qui n'étaient pas forcément
très organoleptiques
c'est faux tant que ce sont des vins qui
sont aussi méritants que d'autres crus
ailleurs notamment des grands crus de
bourgogne ou autre il ya très belles
choses dans le beaujolais
encore faut-il le faire savoir aussi
malgré tous les efforts déployés par
leurs avocats
50 viticulteurs ont été condamnés à de
lourdes amendes de 1000 à 20000 euros
pour falsification de denrées
alimentaires
de son côté abel prénat le principal
intermédiaire du trafic a écopé d'un an
de prison avec sursis et 35 milles euros
damende additifs chimiques âge ou abusif
de sucre mais il ya plus grave
les pesticides entre aussi dans la
composition du vin
en france un quart des pesticides
utilisés par tous les agriculteurs sont
répandus sur les vignes depuis 50 ans
fongicides insecticides herbicides sont
utilisées dans tous les vignobles pour
augmenter les rendements
même si les plus dangereux ont été
interdits certains viticulteurs
utilisent encore des produits toxiques
et pour le consommateur
quels sont les dangers les pesticides se
retrouve-t-il aussi dans les verres de
vin que l'on partage entre amis
non mais ça vraiment très très bon très
agréable pour le savoir nous nous sommes
intéressés aux vins le plus prestigieux
le champagne car c'est aussi l'un des 20
dans la production consomment le plus de
pesticides
nous avons choisi cinq bouteilles parmi
les marques les plus connues en france
pour les faire analyser par un
laboratoire indépendant
les résultats sont surprenants chaque
bouteille contient au minimum 5 résidus
de pesticides
[Musique]
nous présentons ces résultats à françois
veillerette président du mdrgf une
association écologiste
il milite contre la présence de
pesticides dans notre alimentation
il est devenu un spécialiste de ces
produits contre tours le saint chrême
dans le champagne en découvrant nos
analyses de champagne il ne semble pas
surpris et voilà les produits qu'on y
trouve un procès me donne chair et
méthane il en fait toujours les cinq
mêmes avec une moyenne de 48
microgrammes par litre
si on compare à ce qui est admissible
dans de l'eau c'est en moyenne 480 deux
fois supérieur à la limite
admissible pour repondre l'eau du
robinet oui c'est beaucoup plus que ce
que le principe de précaution voudrais
qu'on puisse accepter après ça ça veut
pas dire que vous allez vous effondrez
après avoir bu de fou mort après avoir
bu deux coupes de champagne forcément
mais ça veut dire que vous avez un
niveau de contamination de ses produits
l'accent des produits quand même
inquiétant certains sont cancérigènes
possibles probables certains sont
perturbateur du système hormonal mais il
faut que les producteurs change les
pratiques les modes de culture pour être
beaucoup moins dépendants des pesticides
toutefois les résidus de pesticides que
l'on retrouve dans les bouteilles ne
dépasse pas les limites légales des
normes contestée par les associations
écologistes mais scrupuleusement
respectées par les producteurs
ghislain de montgolfier et le président
de l'union des maisons de champagne
nous lui présentons nos analyses de
résidus de pesticides
200 pesticides donc vous avez un beau
travail parce que vous allez chercher
220 si je puis dire vous avez presque
chercher là la petite bête
la présence de résidus dans chaque
bouteille ne semble pas l'inquiéter pour
autant en fait il faudrait boire environ
1000 bouteilles 500 bouteilles 200
bouteilles ça va dépendre un peu d'un
produit à l'autre par jour pour entrer
dans une éventuelle toxicité
donc je ne pense pas que vu rapidos
analyse il ya un danger c'est toujours
intéressant à voir mais là on n'est pas
en danger
enfin l'objet de déconseillé de boire
100 ou 200 bouteilles de champagne par
jour des pesticides on n'en trouve pas
que dans le champagne
la plupart des vins en contiendrait en
le mdrgf fait analyser par un
laboratoire indépendant
une quarantaine de bordeaux ou de
bourgogne mais aussi des vins allemands
aux chiliens
résultat dans 100% des vins analyser et
même les grands crus on retrouve des
résidus de pesticides
même si les lobbys du champagne et du
vin se veulent rassurants certains
scientifiques considèrent ces résidus de
quelques microgrammes dangereux pour la
santé le professeur belpomme est un
cancérologue engagé qui dénonce
régulièrement les dangers des pesticides
les pesticides ou les substances cmr
sadir cancérigènes mutagènes et
reprotoxiques ceci amplement démontré
non pas voir les centaines d'articles
n'est pas des milliers d'articles
scientifiques publications scientifiques
avec comité de lecture et donc on sait
maintenant pertinemment que c'est pas la
dose qui fait le poison et c'est la
répétition des dose qui fait le poison
autrement dit lorsqu'on a des faibles
doses dans du vin ou dans tout autre
aliment
c'est cancérigène à terme est-ce qu'on
peut consommer encore du vin aujourd'hui
c'est dangereux ou pas on peut consommer
encore du vin aujourd'hui à condition de
le code de le consommer de façon modérée
et si vous voulez à condition que ce vin
on sache d'où ils viennent
que ce soit 24 t et bien sûr qu'il y ait
le moins possible de pesticides si ce
n'est aucun pesticide dedans comment les
fabricants de pesticides explique-t-il
la présence de ces résidus dans les vins
comment communique-t-il sur leurs
produits
pour le savoir nous nous rendons au
salon de l'agriculture
au milieu des espaces de dégustation un
stand un peu particulier celui de luis
pépé l'union de l'industrie de
protection des plantes un nom bucolique
derrière lequel se cache en réalité le
lobby des pesticides
je sens bien
derrière cette vitre une animation
présente au visiteur un vin fabriqué
sans pesticides
torre et la tournée ménard
donc ce vin lorsqu on le sent il elle
sent le vinaigre
donc évidemment ici le représentant de
l'industrie chimique explique au
consommateur qu'un vin réalisé sans
pesticide est imbuvable
lorsqu'on n'est pas de pesticides barre
en général vous n'avez pas devant le
problème c'est que ce n'est pas tout à
fait vrai lorsqu on le pousse dans ses
retranchements il finit par l'admettre
mais un bon vent n'est pas forcément
issus de raisins traités aux pesticides
non parce que le bon vin il est lié à la
vinification il faut il faut déjà du bon
raisin avec du bon raisin pour faire du
mauvais vin ou du bon là donc après j'ai
fait savoir faire du viticulteur et du
vigneron pas des viticulteurs du magnoac
aussi ce que vous montrez là quand même
soulès et des messages qu'il faut être
qu'il faut simple il faut il faut
essayer d'expliquer simplement ce qui se
passe
un message simpliste pour convaincre le
consommateur
et quand on aborde la question délicate
des résidus dans les bouteilles
le discours est tout aussi rôdé dans
certaines études on a retrouvé des
résidus de pesticides dans les vents
parce qu'ils en pensaient alors c'est
normal
le fait que l'on retrouve que l'on
puisse retrouver des traces donc des
résidus de produits sur les denrées
végétales en général et sur le raisin en
particulier est quelque chose qui peut
s'expliquer si on traite trop tard par
rapport à la vendange donc avec des
doses qui ne sont pas les doses
autorisée il ya un dépassement de dos
donc on peut retrouver des traces
en résumé les vignerons seraient les
seuls responsables
pourtant dans le milieu du vin ce n'est
pas l'avis de tout le monde
nous sommes dans la région de sancerre
pour la première fois cet homme accepte
de s'exprimer devant une caméra pendant
trente ans jean marie ballan a travaillé
pour les industriels sa mission
vendre des pesticides aux vignerons
aujourd'hui il a changé de métier et
dénonce les dégâts causés par ces
produits j'en veux aux producteurs de
pesticides
parce que leur message est malhonnête on
a toujours tendance à vouloir vous
expliquer qu'avec les pesticides on a
des beaux produits on va nourrir le
monde etc
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai et comment
vous expliquer cette course infernale
aux cycles chimiques finalement à c'est
un merveilleux parfum d'oseille juste
l'argent l'argent c'est tout c'est juste
une question économique
une course aux profits dangereuses pour
l'environnement et la santé
pour jean-marie ballan si on trouve des
résidus de pesticides dans les vins
c'est surtout parce que les vendeurs de
ces produits pousse les vignerons a
multiplié les traitements quand on
trouve un vigneron qui est prêt à
accepter de consommer qui a peur pour
avoir manqué un seul traitement de paix
toute sa récolte même si le risque
n'existe que dans sa tête et bien on va
continuer à lui vendre un produit
on va pas m'en dissuader c'est une
consommation systématique
une surconsommation qui entraîne la
présence de résidus cancérigènes dans
les bouteilles et ce n'est pas tout
d'après certains scientifiques les
pesticides appauvrissent le terroir et
dégradent le goût du vin direction la
champagne territoire noble par
excellence et vit beaucoup de feuilles
lydia et claude bourguignon sont des
biologistes spécialistes des sols il
conseille les viticulteurs qui
s'inquiètent de l'état de leur vie ces
deux trous de ce matin ils ont
rendez-vous en champagne avec alexandre
chartogne ce jeune vigneron a été obligé
d'arracher toutes ses vignes après
trente ans de traitement aux pesticides
là bas c'est qu'on est de 50 ans là
c'est une ville de 30 ans ces jeunes
allemands h et jeunes pour la raison
qu'elle voit elle avait vraiment des
problèmes d'alimentation facilement oui
t'as vu regarder tout superficiel
baguette que tu as lors d'une
correspondance roitelet l'utilisation
intensive de produits chimiques appauvri
peu à peu le sol les racines des vignes
finissent par remonter à la surface
comme les racines 900 superficie vous
n'avez plus de goût de du fonds alors
qu'au fond vous avez vraiment le
terroirs la typicité du vin paillé
regardez là pour montrer failli s'il
insolent comme celui ci ce n'est pas une
exception
d'après les analyses de claude et lydia
bourguignon en france 80% des sols
serait en mauvais état
pour redonner vie à son terroir
alexandre a décidé de se convertir en
culture biologique une solution loin
d'être idéale à la place des pesticides
chimiques
il utilise du cuivre un produit naturel
le problème c'est que le cuivre polluent
les sols resteront peu près tous les
sept jours on diminue les dozos au
maximum parce que la dose du cuivre est
néfaste pour le seuil pourrait être
néfaste pour la plante donc tout
normalement il faut aussi nous mettre
moins possible pour laisser la ville
s'est développée le meilleures
conditions la culture biologique peut
être aussi néfaste pour l'environnement
malgré tout elle permet de protéger la
santé des vignerons car ce sont eux les
premières victimes des produits de
traitement
raymond shaw et viticulteurs près de
perpignan
il y a trois ans il a failli mourir
d'une aplasie une maladie grave de la
moelle osseuse qui seraient liés aux
pesticides
depuis 20 ans il pulvérise de nombreux
produits chimiques sur ses vignes
aujourd'hui il est guéri de sa maladie
mais ils les utilisent encore c'est dans
ce local sécurisé qui les conserve ses
débuts de stocks de réserve donc qui
font passer un avis dans les jours ou
les semaines qui viennent
j'évite stocker davantage que ça coince
lorsque ça aurait fait flipper j'ai peur
c'est dangereux
j'ai des enfants pas l'eau et j'avais
pas ce que ces choses-là masques à
cartouche au charbon actif
j'ai toujours une avance aussi
raymond manche on est d'autant plus
inquiet qu'il a toujours utilisé masques
gants et combinaisons étanches pour
traiter ses vignes systématique depuis
dix ans je veux protéger un total failli
crever vous étiez conscient de ce danger
là où vous avez découvert
j'ai découvert que j'étais informé mais
bon a toujours l'impression que ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres prises au piège
il est contraint d'utiliser ces produits
chimiques
il travaille au sein d'une coopérative
qui vend sa production aux chaînes de
supermarchés et en cinq ans seulement la
grande distribution leur a imposé de
diviser par trois le prix du vin
normalement il faudra cocher juste avant
son joueur soit ça devient très fragile
comme beaucoup de viticulteurs de la
région
raymond survit grâce au salaire de sa
femme fonctionnaire
il n'a donc pas les moyens de se
reconvertir en culture biologique
on est pris dans l'engrenage du circuit
long de la grande distribution les
intermédiaires s'octroie la part du lion
en matière de marges bénéficiaires et
recourir au bio vous convertir au bio
nous demande de travailler avec 30% des
coûts de production supplémentaires les
produits chimiques sont en cours pour
moi la seule solution d'amener des
récoltes nous des récoltes à terme
une solution rentable mais
potentiellement dangereuse malgré tout
raymond manche on espère un jour tourner
définitivement le dos aux vins chimiques
je rêvais faire ce genre de weil am bio
et un vinyle naturel c'est à dire sans
le verrou sélectionné ni comment le jeu
indigènes sanaa pour le soufre
l'expression la plus pure possible du
terroir lueur d'espoir d'ici 10 ans dans
le vignoble français
la consommation des pesticides doit
chuter de 50% en application du grenelle
de l'environnement
de plus en plus de vignerons produisent
des cuves et sans additifs qu'ils
exportent dans le monde entier le retour
à des vins sain et naturel peut être
l'occasion pour la france de s'imposer
face à la concurrence du nouveau monde